Android patterns for performance
The biggest improvement your app can make is network performance
Relates to the reduction of the absolute number of applications in progress.
But instead of just avoiding syncing the entire data,
How can you accomplish that exactly?
My name is Colt McCannless.
If you are looking for the best way to send orders in batches
To reduce overall network traffic,
Preposition is the solution.
Think of it this way;
Your application is applying for a specific piece of data,
Then sometime in the future being asked for another part of the data,
and so on.
Each individual request has its own associated pressure.
It may eventually lead to a strange pattern of wireless activation each time
To make the request.
Pre-assignment is to predict the type of data that may be contained in those future requests
And capture all those data while there is an active wireless connection.
It is useful here that every wireless request has some pressure
In terms of the time it takes to activate the wireless connection
And battery drain that occurs as a result of continued activation.
Ability to package future orders together and do them now
Means the ability to reduce those pressures
Saving precious battery life.
But prefabrication creates a difficult balancing problem.
If prefetch is less than necessary,
The result is that data transfer rates are not improved effectively.
While prefabrication means too much
The user will wait longer to get the results.
This brings us to our simple question:
How much data do you make up in advance?
Well, the general rule states that on a 3G connection,
Prefetch is good with about 1 megabyte to 5 megabytes of data.
This is of course taking into account
The data will be needed and used by the user.
You can define this differently,
Prefetch as much as the user may need the data
In the next minute or two.
But in fact, one of the most important things to improve is prefetch
Is inevitably the speed of the device connection.
For example, if the user is on a 4G connection,
You may call and bring in 12 new photos,
This takes the same time as pre-fetch
For three images touch 2G.
It is therefore an amendment to the prefetch code
To take into account the quality of the user's connection
It is the best way to make perfect bring cases.
It should be noted that the easiest way to determine the status of the network
Is simply calculating the time it takes to rewind a known piece of content after ordering it.
And with a few simple calculations
A practical research table of common network speeds,
You can quickly determine which network type the user is connected to
And the seizure of applications and applications respectively.
It should also be noted that the greatest benefit here
The execution of motions must be carried out
Their release was delayed but was in the waiting cycle
And future requests,
Or pre-fetching into one active wireless connection window.
And here wonderful things begin to happen.
The good news is that you can update your app to use these styles
Without having to write a huge amount of code.
GCMNetworkManager is an API of Google Play services
Which helps to schedule network-oriented tasks
And manage the transmission in batches for you.
This greatly facilitates the implementation of common patterns,
Such as waiting to connect to the network and attempts to reconnect to the network
And steady decline.
All the wonderful things you need in one API interface are useful.
When it comes to performance,
You need all the APIs you can get
The videos are also useful.
Check out Android Performance Patterns content
Do not miss joining the Google+ community as well.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.